thank you guys for having me don't worry
I won't be doing anything nearly as
complicated as the last two speakers so
it will be a quick five minutes so my
name is Taylor Brownlow I'm a head of
data science at a company called count
at count we are making a data analytics
platform designed for open data so what
that means is we work with companies
like Spotify and Stack Overflow to make
their data really engaging and exciting
allow their users to do more with their
data especially non-technical users so
people who don't know how to use Python
or sequel can use our tool to find
really interesting things and share it
in addition to working with different
companies we also do our own kind of
kind of special data topics so for
example right now we write down one with
movies so we're trying to create the
ultimate movies data set essentially so
anytime you want it to go have a
conversation about movie data or do some
kind of in-depth data analytics instead
of going to twelve different sources all
around the internet you could just come
to us so that's basically what I'm going
to be talking about is how we've tried
to solve this problem and hopefully
maybe ask you guys to help if you are
interested so yeah like I said in this
world of movies and as you can imagine
and most topics the data that's
available to you it comes from many many
different places and to put them all
together it can be quite difficult
challenge or else people would have done
it the one that I'm going to talk about
in particular is how we took Oscars data
from Wikipedia and merged it with data
from the movie database the movie
database is basically an open platform
that allows users to go and vote on
different movies at different data for
different movies and everyone knows
Wikipedia so basically if we wanted to
use these two together in any kind of
relational format we would need to
assign every row in the Wikipedia data
set a movie ID from the movie database
the problems here are a few it's mainly
you need to do this looking at movie
title
especially so you've got different
things so obviously I'm American so the
movie is the Sorcerer's Stone but you
guys would call it with philosopher's
stone which means those two movies don't
match up in those data sets and frankly
most programs wouldn't really see that
those two words were that similar so
what else is there
well there are 21 films called
Cinderella case you didn't know which is
amazing and it can be quite challenging
also specifically around the Oscars data
set especially we go back in like the
1930s some movies were actually
nominated for awards upwards of 20 years
after they came out I don't know why
they were and also well there's the main
ones but it gets quite difficult in some
real niche use cases if we look at what
I did I'll preface this by saying there
probably many other ways to do this that
may be more elegant but this works so I
was happy with it
basically what we want to do is we want
to obviously pre process these titles to
get them to be another raw form that
we're going to turn these titles into
vectors we can start to compare them I
use cosine similarity to compare the
resulting vectors and then found for any
input from the Wikipedia dataset what's
the movie from the movie database that
has the largest cosine similarity and
took the top one there's a few other
kind of things that added to the code to
one make it run a little bit faster and
to increase the results so obviously
pre-filtering the movie database for
things that should be matching so movies
that came out around the same time it
does it and movies that were kind of
highly voted were a better chance of
being matches to movies that have been
nominated for Oscars essentially this is
really embarrassing code but that's how
you do it it was never meant to be
looked at by 300 people so but there it
is
essentially what we're asking for there
now is we're trying to keep this
momentum up especially around this movie
data set
and how do we build this thing out to be
really the place that you go and look
for movie data so one of the things we
are also not hiring but we are asking
for people like yourselves who kind of
really love data and love getting into
these these kinds of messy problems if
you were interested in trying to
contribute to this big problem that
we're trying to tackle please do let me
know and yeah be really great to hear
you guys thoughts and I will be around
you guys have questions or
[Applause]